Traduttore: Claude Almansi
Revisore: Elisabetta Siagri
Un ricercatore che si occupa di clima
è un po' come uno che lavora
nella sala macchine
della nostra astronave,
in questo caso il nostro pianetino,
e vi avverte che c'è qualcosa
che non funziona.
Abbiamo un problema con l'impianto
di riscaldamento e di condizionamento,
e il problema rischia di trasformarsi
in qualcosa di grave,
se non interveniamo in tempo.
Ecco perché dobbiamo oggi capire
da dove viene questo problema
e, con tanti anni di ricerca scientifica,
si è individuato il fattore
che non funziona,
e questo fattore è il fatto che
i 200 anni di Rivoluzione Industriale,
che ci hanno dato tanta prosperità
e ci hanno portato alla straordinaria
quantità di mezzi tecnologici
di cui disponiamo,
non erano gratis.
Hanno lasciato dei sottoprodotti negativi,
in particolare i residui della combustione
del petrolio, del carbone e del gas, che
hanno aumentato i gas a effetto serra,
ma non ci sono solo quelli, ci sono anche
tanti altri fattori inquinanti
che possiamo vedere in una curva che
era prima e che è l'impronta ecologica,
cioè è quell'insieme delle risorse
che noi preleviamo dal pianeta,
tutto ciò che usiamo: da un legno
di una foresta,
i pesci che peschiamo nell'oceano,
i minerali che estraiamo e i rifiuti
che reimmettiamo dopo nell'ambiente.
Allora noi vediamo che fino al 1970,
con un mondo che era popolato
da tre miliardi e mezzo di persone,
la metà di quelli che ci sono oggi -
siamo attorno ai sette miliardi e mezzo -
era ancora in equilibrio
con gli interessi della natura:
prelevava nell'anno e alla fine,
il 31 dicembre, possiamo dire
ripartiva, con il 1 gennaio, la produzione
della natura dell'anno successivo.
Ma abbiamo continuato
una crescita smodata,
senza tenere conto degli allarmi
che già in quegli anni i miei predecessori
avevano portato all'umanità
e il risultato è che oggi consumiamo
una terra e mezza:
la mezza terra è tutto ciò che
non ci sarà più per le generazioni future
ed è anche l'eredità scomoda
dei cambiamenti climatici,
dell'inquinamento,
della estinzione di specie
che lasciamo al futuro.
Se non vogliamo arrivare alla bancarotta
della natura, cioè con un mondo dove
la popolazione aumenta sempre di più,
i consumi e gli inquinamenti ancor di più,
noi dobbiamo cambiare oggi percorso,
dobbiamo rientrare all'interno dei limiti
fisici dell'unico pianeta che abbiamo.
Semplice, no?
Se continuiamo a crescere verso
i tre pianeti, che sono previsti
come necessità fisiche della nostra
avidità di specie attorno già al 2050,
la natura fa bancarotta e i danni
potrebbero essere irreversibili
per le generazioni future.
Il cambiamento climatico è il problema
forse più ampio, più vasto,
di cui sentiamo più parlare.
E sappiamo oggi che la temperatura
è aumentata sul pianeta
di circa un grado nell'ultimo secolo.
La maggior parte di questo aumento termico
è molto recente:
negli ultimi 30 anni si impone
con una straordinaria forza,
perché il 2016 è stato
l'anno più caldo della storia,
preceduto dal 2015,
preceduto dal 2014.
Insomma vediamo ormai
una sequenza importante
di una rampa di aumento della temperatura
che è il sintomo della malattia climatica
del nostro pianeta.
Qual è la causa?
Ormai l'abbiamo identificata:
è la CO2, l'anidride carbonica,
il biossido di carbonio
di origine fossile,
perché di CO2 ce n'è tanta nel pianeta,
ma una parte è quella
nel ciclo della fotosintesi,
le piante la prendono dall'aria:
fotosintesi.
Noi mangiamo un panino al salame,
dentro il pane, dentro il salame,
non c'è altro che
una parte di quel carbonio
che noi usiamo per vivere,
lo restituiamo respirando:
è un ciclo chiuso.
Quello che entra esce
e ritorna dov'era prima.
Ma liberando il carbone, petrolio e gas
che stavano sottoterra da milioni di anni,
noi abbiamo aggiunto
una notevole quantità,
attualmente sono 36 miliardi
di tonnellate all'anno di CO2,
che vanno in atmosfera
e cambiano quindi la composizione chimica,
arrivando a 400 parti per milione
che sono un numero straordinario:
400 parti per milione vogliono dire
una quantità di CO2 nell'aria
che non si rilevava da almeno
800.000 anni.
Lo sappiamo attraverso i carotaggi
che sono stati fatti al Polo Sud
dove bollicine di aria fossile
incluse dentro il ghiaccio antico,
analizzate in laboratorio, ci dicono:
"Guarda che il massimo assoluto
di quantità di CO2 nell'aria
in 800.000 anni si è toccato
una volta sola attorno a 330.000 anni fa,
con il valore di 300 parti per milione.
Quindi da 300 a 400 è tutta roba nostra.
È danno recente, è il cambiamento recente
dell'atmosfera terrestre
che come effetti ha
l'aumento della temperatura
perché la CO2 è il principale gas
a effetto serra,
svolge un po' la funzione
di una sorta di coperta chimica
che scalda il pianeta.
I sintomi, quindi, li vediamo già;
con quell'aumento di un grado
in un secolo,
i ghiacciai -- i ghiacciai sono
un bel termometro naturale
che materializza quello che ci dicono
i dati misurati dagli strumenti --
sulle Alpi abbiamo questi testimoni muti
che sono in terribile riduzione:
abbiamo perso il 50% della loro superficie
soltanto in un secolo.
Cioè l'effetto di un grado,
lo vediamo attraverso
la perdita del ghiaccio delle Alpi,
ma anche nelle Ande,
ma anche in Himalaya,
ma anche nelle Montagne Rocciose
ma anche al Polo Nord e in Groenlandia.
Allora il nostro futuro,
le simulazioni matematiche del clima
che ormai vengono fatte
da oltre 50 anni circa,
sono diventate veramente affidabili.
Eppur nell'incertezza
di prevedere il futuro,
ci dicono almeno qualcosa di importante
per scegliere la traiettoria
più ragionevole.
Se continuiamo ad inquinare
come facciamo oggi
e seguiamo il grafico che ci porta
ai tre pianeti
nell'impronta ecologica generale
della terra,
noi rischiamo di avere al 2100
un aumento di circa cinque gradi
nella temperatura terrestre,
che è veramente una catastrofe ecologica,
una catastrofe soprattutto per noi,
non per la natura;
la natura cambia, evolverà,
si adatterà a cinque gradi in più,
ma l'uomo si adatterà?
No, perché non ha la capacità,
soprattutto per variazioni così rapide,
per una società così complessa
come la nostra, di adattarsi.
Allora la scelta è quella di seguire
la parte più bassa del grafico,
in questo caso, la linea azzurra, che
con una dieta ferrea
sulla nostra economia,
ci permetterà di mantenere
l'aumento della temperatura,
entro il 2100, in due gradi.
Due gradi sono meglio di cinque.
Non saranno una passeggiata,
perché vuol dire ancora aggiungere uno
a quello che è già salito
dalla fine del 1800,
ma vuol dire comunque avere maggiori
capacità di adattamento e di reazione.
Il protocollo, l'accordo firmato a Parigi
nel dicembre del 2015
vuole proprio questo.
Vuole farci ridurre le emissioni
per ridurre l'aumento della temperatura
e per ridurre anche l'aumento
del livello dei mari,
perché i ghiacciai che fondono
fanno aumentare i mari,
il riscaldamento delle acque le dilata.
Attualmente gli oceani della terra
crescono già di circa
tre millimetri all'anno,
ma più scaldiamo e più cresceranno.
Risultato finale: se scegliamo
la strada dei cinque gradi, la peggiore,
avremo anche almeno
un metro di oceano in più a fine secolo.
Se conteniamo l'inquinamento
e il riscaldamento in due gradi,
avremo mezzo metro circa di mare in più.
È sempre un problema, soprattutto
per qualche zona molto vicina a noi
che conosciamo bene,
ma è un problema che possiamo
maneggiare meglio
rispetto a un aumento di un metro.
Allora, come vedete, ci sono
gravi malfunzionamenti del sistema
ma il fatto che noi ne siamo responsabili
ci mette in una posizione
in fondo costruttiva.
Possiamo anche decidere
di riparare il guasto in sala macchine.
Abbiamo tanti obiettivi
che sono riconosciuti
da tutte le organizzazioni internazionali
e che da temo sentiamo risuonare
nelle nostre orecchie
sotto forma di economia verde
e cose di questo genere.
Solo che devono diventare la priorità.
Non devono essere degli optional.
Devono essere una via corale
condivisa per tutta l'umanità;
si deve fare solo quello.
Quella è l'unica cosa intelligente
che possiamo fare.
Se si rompe la macchina
è un problema grave,
non possiamo più ripararla.
Allora, in breve, la ricettina delle cose
che ragionevolmente possiamo fare già oggi
sulla quale poi ne potremo innestare altre
che cresceranno con l'impegno,
con lo studio, con l'innovazione:
dobbiamo ridurre il consumo
delle risorse non rinnovabili.
Prima di tutto, il consumo dei suoli.
Più cementifichiamo, più creiamo problemi:
aumentiamo il rischio di alluvioni,
abbiamo meno acqua che si depura
scendendo nelle falde,
abbiamo meno intercettazione di CO2
da parte della fotosintesi
e ci togliamo la cosa più importante,
il suolo per produrre cibo
per il futuro dell'umanità.
Quindi fermiamo il consumo dei suoli.
Facciamo meno rifiuti
e ricicliamoli tutti.
Sono cose che si possono fare,
non sono cose difficili;
la raccolta differenziata
ma anche agire alla fonte.
Il miglior rifiuto è quello non prodotto.
È già la mano che si muove
nel nostro gesto di acquistare
che sceglie il rifiuto di domani.
Altrimenti i rifiuti creano
un danno grave, non solo al clima,
perché dietro al rifiuto
c'è un consumo energetico,
ma anche alla vita, perché i rifiuti
che vanno sopratutto in mare
costituiscono una grave minaccia
per tutta la fauna marina
che si nutre per esempio della plastica
e nel passaggio successivo
ce la porta nel piatto a noi,
con tutto il danno sanitario
che arriva dagli additivi tossici
che vi sono contenuti.
Passiamo rapidamente
alle energie rinnovabili.
Sono già mature per essere usate
su larga scala.
Si può fare: pannelli fotovoltaici,
collettori solari, turbine eoliche,
biomasse.
Tutto dove si può, ricorriamo a energia
fatta con le forze della natura.
E, ovviamente, accanto a questo,
ci deve essere il risparmio
e l'efficienza.
Siamo una società che spreca
moltissima energia.
Quindi ne usiamo di meno,
la usiamo meglio
e quella che usiamo la andiamo a prendere
dalle forze naturali,
dal sole, dall'acqua, dal vento,
dalle biomasse.
Dobbiamo cambiare un po'
anche le nostre abitudini.
Viaggiare è bello, viaggiare è importante,
ma sicuramente viaggiare in aereo,
non tanto.
Inquina assai, produce grandi emissioni
di CO2 per unità di passeggero.
Quando facciamo un volo intercontinentale,
purtroppo,
produciamo tanta CO2 come
utilizzare un'auto per un anno.
Quindi dobbiamo essere
più responsabili nelle scelte.
Viaggiare in aereo è una cosa importante.
Facciamola solo se è importante
veramente anche per noi
e non per andare a prendere il caffè
da qualche parte
e gloriarci al lunedì in ufficio
che abbiamo fatto un week-end oltreoceano.
Diamo un valore alla tecnologia
che ci offre delle possibilità,
per esempio, più telelavoro.
Macchine elettriche non risolveranno
tutti i problemi del mondo,
ma si può fare molto, magari, se caricate
con i panelli fotovoltaici,
arrivano a ridurre fortemente
le emissioni.
Favorire l'agricoltura di prossimità.
Perché far viaggiare le fragole
oltreoceano a gennaio?
Ogni fragola che mangiate oggi a gennaio
è in realtà un cucchiaino di petrolio.
Recuperiamo una produzione locale.
Insomma, siamo un po'
alla vigilia di una guerra mondiale.
Winston Churchill, col quale io avevo
in comune esclusivamente il papillon,
nel 1934 si lamentava che nessuno
reagiva alla Germania nazista
che si stava riarmando.
Nel '36 dice: "Ragazzi, troppo tardi",
queste cose le dice al parlamento inglese,
"Qui ormai siamo entrati nell'era
delle conseguenze.
La prevenzione bisognava farla prima".
Le conseguenze le conosciamo tutti
e cominceranno nel 1939
col più terribile conflitto dell'umanità.
Ecco, in quel momento,
Churchill diventa un leader.
Non dice: "Ah, ve l'avevo detto", ma dirà:
"Non mollate, continuiamo, perché
possiamo ancora farcela".
Siamo in questa situazione.
Avanti, da stasera io vorrei
che cominciate tutti a fare
il vostro piccolo gesto
per salvare il futuro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)